the month-long build-up of russian
troops on the border with ukraine has
turned now into an invasion
ukraine under attack
military bases airports and aircraft
have been targeted and bombed
the skies over multiple cities including
the capital kiev lit up waking up
residents in the early hours of thursday
as russian artillery advanced not very
many could have
you know predicted that he would be
striking at so many multiple targets
the civilian casualties are unknown
though russia says it will only attack
military posts
as a response ukraine has declared
martial law
[Music]
i had a conversation with us president
joe biden the u.s is starting to gather
international support
today we need you each of you to be calm
if possible stay at home please we are
working the army is working the entire
security and defense sector of ukraine
is working
these attacks come after russian
president vladimir putin declared two
separatist areas in the donbass region
in eastern ukraine as independent and
said russian civilians who live there
need protection
the battle for luhansk and donetsk in
eastern ukraine has been going on since
2014 with more than 14 000 people killed
in fighting between russian-backed
separatists and the ukrainian army
now putin has demanded ukrainian forces
retreat
whoever would try to stop us and further
create threats to our country to our
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and lead you
to such consequences that you have never
faced in your history we are ready for
any outcome
the operation began despite last-ditch
appeals from members of the un security
council to ease tension
ukraine's ambassador to the un demanded
his russian counterpart stepped down as
chairman call putin call lavrov
to stop aggression
there is no purgatory for war criminals
they go straight to hell ambassador
in a statement u.s president joe biden
warned of a catastrophic loss of life
and human suffering there's a mood of
desperation developing now many people
just jumping into their cars getting
their families together and heading on
the road trying to get to poland
but the main auto routes are all jammed
there are so many people trying to do
the same thing others are going
underground taking shelter the missiles
are getting closer now
emergency meetings have been called to
reach an agreement while the shelling
and buildup of military troops on both
sides continues
this is ukraine's darkest day
andrew simmons al jazeera kiev
right let's start talking to our teams
on the ground first it's hoda abdul
hamid she is in kramatosk in eastern
ukraine tell us about what you've been
seeing and hearing hoda
well certainly there is a bit of panic
among people actually while i was
standing here waiting to talk to you one
woman came up to me asking me why i was
wearing this gear and that we were
actually frightening people even more by
our presence in the city another one
came up to me showed me her credit card
and said there is no more money in the
cash machine there are no dollars there
are no ryfners which is a local currency
and she did look if you looked at her
eyes she did look quite panicked but the
city is calm since these morning
explosions the pre-dawn explosions we
haven't heard
anything uh since however i'm just gonna
get out of the shot you can see all the
shops are completely
shut down businesses restaurants
everything is shut down there are people
on the street but this would be a busier
time uh normally
simply because we are actually in the
city center of uh kramatorsk so
people are following the news people are
worried um the bus station that connects
the different region is now closed it's
all the train is also
working
sporadically so people's only choice is
to try to get into their car and go
somewhere even though as i said again
danger is still not here but they are
following what's happening at the front
line is about 90 kilometers away from
here and in certain points and not many
but the uh we believe the the
pro-russian separatists have managed to
break through that front line and to end
advance uh certainly we know that in one
point along the front line and we are
hearing other reports of that but we
cannot confirm that at the moment
because the situation is fluid there are
a lot of rumors and counter rumors but
certainly people
are beginning to realize what's
happening it's sinking in and panic is
beginning to set really
how to stay there for a sec if you can
uh the team's just telling me about some
new pictures we've just gotten in can we
roll those pictures guys uh russian
tanks
uh apparently coming in to
luhansk
uh
so yeah sorry i'm just running through a
few different things here okay there
you've got the tank there's waiting for
it to come through okay so that is the
definitive sign of uh russian tanks i
also just want to
can we take those
show those pictures as well if the uh of
the russian president just now just
really quickly
just noticing this on some of my screens
here that's the prime minister of
uh pakistan imran khan who's visiting
with vladimir putin as well not live
pictures this has just come in a moment
ago
so vladimir putin taking a a a foreign
minister
prime minister and for a visit as well
on the day that he has ordered a
military operation in a neighbouring
country lots happening there sorry i
just wanted to get to all of those
pictures hot abdulhamid as well with us
uh from chromatos tell us i saw one of
your reports earlier as well hodder from
one of the uh supermarkets wasn't it
which is uh well the shelves rapidly
becoming quite bare
yes absolutely i mean i think what
happened is that people were quite blase
about it all um you know over the past
few weeks we've been going around this
eastern side and many uh had brushed
away the idea of an invasion even as far
as care people had brushed out the idea
of an invasion and then sort of the
rhetoric ramped up and the threats
ramped up but they still stayed quite a
blase especially in this part of the
country now you have to understand that
these cities are quite divided are quite
mixed you do have the russia does have a
lot of support in many of these cities
some of them it's a 50 50 otherwise it
could be overwhelmingly uh pro-russian
and that's what makes it so difficult
for the ukrainian soldiers at the front
line so people did not
make their preparations people did not
really believe that all that would
happen and people sort of those who do
support russia did do feel safe uh that
if they indeed come here well then
they would be they nothing would happen
to them but then comes the reality then
comes the explosions then comes the
sounds then comes the pictures and that
starts to frighten people whether
whether whatever side they sit on and i
think that's what's been happening here
in the city because i remember around
eight nine o'clock we were going live i
was looking around people were going to
their office
they seemed to be going about their
normal day well it looks very different
at this point in town in time um now
there's no there's barely any queue at
the atm simply because there's no more
cash there and the streets are empty and
the businesses apart from the
supermarkets and maybe a few kiosks are
completely shut down put that all
together happening not only in crema
tours we're in several towns and cities
around the eastern ukraine and that
increases the anxiety among people the
uncertainty of what could happen
what an extraordinary time it is thank
you hot abdulhamid
kramatosk eastern ukraine
now
to one of our other team and this is
charles stratford who is in uh mariupol
the port city there he's been reporting
from the ground the explosions heard
there in that key port city have a look
at his report
we've heard loud bangs of explosions and
interestingly it's the first time so far
today where we've heard that distinctive
sound of grad rockets
being used it's a
rapid fire flooding
these are rockets that land in in rapid
succession um and are highly obviously
highly dangerous the sort of rockets
that we saw
being used during the 2014 2015 war
between the separatists and the
ukrainians now i'm going to flip the
camera around i don't know whether
you're going to be able to see this but
across the field there you may be able
to see smoke rising i suppose from me
it's about
i don't know quarter of a kilometer away
or so we understand that that is a
military um
installation that uh has been hit smoke
has been billowing from it for about the
last hour and a half or so there's more
smoke coming out from what we understand
our military installations beyond that i
suppose about another half a kilometer
or so
and here's the sign and the reason why
i'm showing this sign is because it's of
significance the the top word you see
there the town is merely a topple and
we've been talking earlier today about
what analysts say could be an attempt by
russian forces to create a corridor
from the donbass region the eastern
areas held by the separatists to crimea
okay that is ukraine covered off with
two correspondents there let's flip over
to moscow uh and bring in dawson jabari
our correspondent there
is that what we're going to do
yep let's talk to door so hi dorset so
i'd like you to tell us about what the
russians have been saying separately to
the message for the ukrainian military
and the messages to the ukrainian people
well kamal we've just been hearing from
the kremlin spokesperson dmitry peskov
who a few minutes ago said that um the
goal is to neutralize the military
potential of kiev that is officially
what russia is trying to do at the
moment and
he went on to say that the
uh kremlin kremlin is not excluding the
possibility of negotiations between
putin and zielinski if ukraine is ready
to talk about moscow's security concerns
um and that um
the possible about the accusations that
russia is looking for a possible regime
change in ukraine and he uh said that
this is a question for um of choice for
of the ukrainian people um i think this
comes at a time when there's been a lot
of accusations thrown at the government
here that they're trying to overthrow
the officials in kiev who they have
accused of being weak in the past
the
president vladimir putin had said that
um the ukrainian president is a puppet
of the west and that is why uh that this
their their country is in such a state
they are not uh basically in charge
they're not representing the entire
population
in terms of the message out of here for
the ukrainian people the russian defense
ministry has said that they are
targeting military installations in
ukraine they are not targeting civilians
the officials have said that they are
not
causing alarm they don't want to cause
alarm to the general population of
ukraine of course it's going to be very
difficult because some of those military
installations that we've seen already
are in heavily populated areas
in cities in ukraine so
we just have to wait and see how this
unfolds in the coming hours we expect
vladimir putin who's currently meeting
with the prime minister of
pakistan who arrived um in moscow late
last night to speak to the media
following that meeting probably in the
next few hours and we'll see what he has
to say since he broadcast that message
early at 6 a.m moscow time making the
announcement that russia was going into
ukraine to assist with the separatists
in the eastern part of ukraine who were
fighting with the ukraine military was
that a pre i'm guessing that was a
pre-planned visit by imran khan because
it seems an odd time to be accepting a a
visit from a world leader when you're
basically just gone to war
absolutely this was on the calendar for
vladimir putin from about a week ago or
so and we saw footage of imran khan
landing in moscow where he was greeted
by officials and he uh was um he said
that it's quite an exciting time to be
in moscow obviously not realizing what
was to come in the few hours after that
statement
but we also have i also have to mention
that the um there have been a number of
flights that have been canceled uh
certain areas of russia's airspace have
been closed off to civilian flights as a
result of the ongoing operations they're
carrying out in ukraine um and we
they've said that they are closing
certain portions of the airspace in the
country until march 2nd
so i think
this will be certainly the last
high-ranking official who'll be visiting
vladimir putin for the foreseeable
future
cool thanks daughter
talk to you again soon
plenty of condemnation out there today
we'll start with this from the european
union foreign policy chief joseph
burrell who's spoken alongside the eu
commission president ursula vondeline
they're in brussels
these are
among the darkest hour
for europe since the end of world war ii
a major nuclear power
has attacked
a neighbor country
and is strengthening reprisals
of any other states
that may come
to its rescue
this is not only the greatest violation
of international law
it's a violation of the basic principles
of human coexistence
it's costing many lives
with unknown consequences
ahead of us
later today we will present a package of
massive and targeted sanctions
to european leaders for approval
with this package
we will target strategic sectors
of the russian economy
by blocking their access
to technologies and markets that are key
for russia
we will weaken russia's economic base
and its capacity to modernize
and in addition we will freeze russian
assets in the european union
and stop the access
of russian banks to european financial
financial markets